did you ever deal with any sort of like
anxiety or any kind of depression like
as a kid
yeah I mean I definitely feel
there was anxiety towards
you know performing and doing the best
thing is the pressure like as my
character built for instance yeah oh
gosh will I do justice to this rock
character that people love you know so
that was always kind of hard to do
especially when you know inevitably
a lot of the scenes of every character
kind of was chopped down from the book
to the film so you kind of didn't really
have as much to kind of show in the film
so sometimes that was a little
disappointing because there were parts
of the character that just didn't get to
come through
um because there weren't the scenes to
do that so that made me feel like a bit
anxious or just frustrated I guess yeah
yeah because as great as you were in in
the movies it's like you know some
people say you were you know you were
underserved or like you know it's like
you know the book she should have been
more explored this character was even
better you know you could have they
could have made it you know and then of
course the the contrast or the the you
know I'm sure they thought we have so
many so much to do and so little time
and whatever but I'm sure it was a
battle the older you get and the more
you realize this is an integral part of
the movie the franchise and I want my
character did you have conversations
with the producers about it I mean not
really I just don't think you I mean
there was just no room for much change
in those scripts like those million
Executives like going through them all
and I think what I maybe took which I
don't take so much to heart now is I
kind of felt that like
you know maybe my anxiety was about like
oh I'm going to be seen as like badly
portraying this character rather than
later realizing perception really given
the opportunity to do that so it wasn't
really my
you know
fault exactly yeah hey there folks it's
Michael Rosenbaum and boy have I got a
huge announcement for you this has been
a long time coming and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there you know when
when fans do share that kind of
disappointment and they they do it in a
way that like we know we want you we
want more of you and you know that's the
same with every character I mean if only
they could have been five hour long
movies but it would have taken probably
two years to film each yeah